- All right y'all, my
special Valentine's Day hour
has nearly come to an end.
I know you're sad about it,
but I have one more story
of love to share with you.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
So this begins with Lamb, a
Nigerian man who only recently
moved to the states to be with his wife.
As you can imagine, it
doesn't snow much in Nigeria,
so when the flakes started
piling up at his new home
in Connecticut, he knew
exactly what he had to do.
- [Ling] You ready to go back inside?
- [Lamb] No, there is this
thing I always see all Americans
they are doing it,
me too I want to do it today.
- [Ling] What?
- I don't know what they call
it, but it goes like this.
(Ling laughing)
- [Ling] It goes like this.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Applause.
- I've always wanted to do this thing.
I've been waiting.
I'm doing it!
(Ling laughing)
What do they call it?
- [Ling] Snow angel.
- Snow angel.
- Look at his first snow angel, guys.
(audience applauding)
- They are so adorable!
We love them so much!
We have Lamb and his wife
Ling on the line right now.
What's up, y'all?
(audience applauding)
Oh my God, well first of all,
you both look fabulous right now!
Y'all look so attractive
right now, way to go.
I love how you look right now.
(Kelly laughing)
So Lamb, this snow angel
has been a goal of yours
for a while, right?
- First, thank you for having us here.
You know, since I moved to America,
to be with my beautiful wife here Ling,
you know, I've only seen people,
you know, doing it.
Like I see kids jump down,
what is this butterfly
thing they are doing?
And by the way, it doesn't snow at all,
we don't have snow in Nigeria,
So this day, it snowed and we were about
to go back inside.
You know and she said "Let's go inside"
and I said "No" because
it's been on my bucket list.
I said "today I will do this thing."
You know, so I dropped on the snow
and I just started making it.
(Lamb laughing)
- Oh my god, well I'm gonna help you out,
because I kept seeing
you make that snow angel,
and I was like "I know that
there is snow getting right
in your pants and in your shirt"
'cause it was like, you
gotta wear a snow bib,
you gotta wear a snow
bib to make a snow angel,
so the snow doesn't get in your clothes.
Just a little tip for next time.
So Ling this part is so crazy,
tell everyone how you met.
- Yeah, so thanks again
for having us Kelly,
it was a really crazy story,
so Lamb is an afro dance hall artist,
and so when he came here
about 4 years ago to America,
for his prison reform work,
'cause he's also an
advocate for prison reform.
He wanted to shoot his first music video,
like, first music video in America.
And he was like "all
right, who could I find?"
Him and his organizers who weirdly enough
happened to be my mom, crazy story,
was like "Well my daughter's
an actress and a model,
maybe she'll be interested",
and so Lamb was like, he saw my picture
and was like "I want
that girl in my video."
So we met and just collab and combine over
our philanthropic efforts.
He's released over 120
wrongfully convicted felons
in Nigeria,
- Wow!
- He's doing that here.
We love community, and just,
you know, photographing,
documenting our experience
has made us so happy
and that's how Ling and Lamb started.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh! Hey
Lamb, congratulations!
That's amazing what
you're doing for people.
And it's so cool how y'all met,
and now it totally makes
sense why y'all look
so highly attractive.
I was like "wait, what?"
Well thank you so much Lamb and Ling!
Good luck in life!
I'm liking your post right now.
Remember Lamb, you gotta get a snow bib,
so the snow doesn't get
in there, man, it's cold!
That's not all though our
season one partner pilot pen
makers of friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show
wanna celebrate those
creating memories fearlessly,
just like y'all.
So they're gonna give you $1000,
how's that sound?
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughing)
Oh my god, Lamb!
- [Lamb] Wait, I didn't-
- [Kelly] Lamb!
- [Lamb] Kelly, wait!
- Lamb, you win for best reaction!
- Thank you!
- No, absolutely, thank you guys so much!
(Kelly laughing)